hello everyone wanted to welcome you all
to the comparative media studies writing
colloquium uh tonight is our tremendous
honor
to hear from my colleague the brilliant
Helen Elaine Lee who will read from her
the latest novel pomegranate and just a
couple of words about cmsw about
colloquium uh universities like MIT are
always with their breath almost
impossible to grasp I think it's
probably
um just uh the fact that I'm a CMS
person that you can get a sense of what
a place like MIT does best
um at a place like cmsw our colloquium
in many ways
is where Mi can meets itself where the
Sciences the social science and the
United Arts come together and uh Helen
is uh absolutely emblematic of that kind
of meeting and that kind of achieves I
wanted to bring up my colleague
who will introduce Ellen uh novelist
fantastic book uh if you haven't read it
go see them really just
just talk about two powerhouses and
Fatima please thank you so much
[Music]
hi everybody Welcome
um it's lovely to be here my name is
Fatina boss I am a lecturer in fiction
writing in cmsw and it's my honor today
to introduce Professor Helen Elaine Lee
and her new novel pomegranate which came
out in April and has received some rave
reviews which I'll get to in a moment
but before I get to the reviews I'd like
to talk about my experience of the novel
I first heard Helen give a reading from
Pomegranate in the spring and the
reading was so beautiful and so moving
that I literally had tears in my eyes
which doesn't often happen to me at
readings and I don't think I was the
only one in the room in that condition
um so I was really looking forward to
the book and finally had the pleasure to
read it over the summer and I have to
say that pomegranate lived up to that
first deep impression uh Helen's reading
made on me it's the beautifully told
story of Renita Atwater just released
from prison after a four years sentence
for opiate possession and it tells of
her struggle and fight to reunite with
her children her family to overcome The
Temptations and traumas of her past and
to build a new future as she also looks
back on this transformative experience
of love she has in prison with a woman
another fellow inmate
for me as a reader pomegranate does what
literature and the novel especially do
best which is to take me so deeply and
profoundly and poetically into the
experience of another person that my own
sense of humanity and empathy and
compassion is enlarged
and I'm not the only one who is deeply
impressed by the book pomegranate was
selected as one of the top 10 books of
the Year by Amazon the Amazon editor who
writes about the novel says this empathy
expanding novel is like a pomegranate
break it open and you'll find a treasure
Trove inside BuzzFeed news states that
Lee writes beautifully about the healing
power of black kin networks queer love
Community Support Systems and literature
it has received starred reviews from
Publishers Weekly and book list
Publishers Weekly rights that with a
light poetic touch Lee balances the
painful details of renita's reality with
genuine persistent hope for New
Beginnings it's irresistible and I can
go on and on but I'd also like to
mention the acclaimed authors who have
also praised the novel including tayari
Jones who writes with empathy insight
and hope pomegranate reveals the hidden
heartbreak of the women touched by
incarceration prepared to be challenged
and changed and Jacqueline Woodson who
writes the talent Elaine Lee has brought
such a deep and beautiful world of
people to the page in their survival we
find ours and we are left grateful
different better
so this is pomegranate but before I
close I also want to say a little more
about Professor Lee Beyond pomegranate
Professor Lee is of course professor of
comparative media studies writing here
at MIT in addition to this latest novel
pomegranate she is also the acclaimed
author of the novels the Serpent's gift
and watermarked and her writing has
appeared in magazines and anthologies
including plowshares callaloo parachuter
hanging loose best African-American
fiction as well as the New York Times
book review amongst other places
though I haven't been at MIT long I've
been here long enough to know that
Helen's contribution to the MIT
Community has also been profound to cmsw
to women's and gender studies to Black
studies and in creating a space for
creative writing here at the University
outside of the University Helen is has
also served on the board of pan New
England for 10 years during which time
she served on its freedom to write
committee and volunteered with its
prison creative writing program which
she also helped establish
incarceration as a symptom of trauma as
a condition evoking histories of slavery
and oppression as a space of suffering
as well as possibility are all important
themes in Professor Elise work and
pomegranate treats these themes
beautifully so again I congratulate
Professor Lee on the novel and without
further Ado I present to you Professor
Helen Elaine Lee and pomegranate thank
you
um
I'm gonna move the soil
oh thank you thank you Fatin for that
for that introduction and this is a
lovely chance for all of you to meet her
new member of cmsw wonderful fiction
writer do you know as Juno mentioned of
the novel ghost season which came out
this spring and I also wanted to mention
another new member of of my department
Brianna Williams who writes on powerful
fiction and non-fiction and teaches both
and it's so exciting to have these two
talented sisters join our community
a huge thank you to Ken Manning my
colleague and dear friend who has
supported me in my writing about the
lives of imprisoned people from the very
first and who arranged and organized
this event and to I want to thank Ruth
Perry who's going to lead the Q a after
I read she's also been there with
support and love from the beginning of
my 28 years at MIT
thanks also to LBGTQ plus Services
women's and gender services and the
office of Multicultural engagement for
co-sponsoring the event
um and to my colleague and dear friend
Joaquin taranas and student Savannah
Lawrence who helped to to get the word
out about the event and finally to well
not finally to Belmont books for coming
to sell the books tonight and to all of
you for being here so is this mic on
because it does yeah connect
I don't think so either because
so okay
so there isn't a mic that helps me be
heard or okay it's hard I I have a soft
voice so I thought we would have that
okay
in any case so in uh in pomegranate
Renita Atwater tells her story of
getting out of Oak Hills prison after a
four-year bid for opiate possession
and trying to stay clean repair her
relationships with her kids own her love
for the women on the inside who's helped
to inspire her and grapple to accept and
tell her full and complex story
and renita's voice is intercut with that
of a third person narrator who brings
alive the history revealing some of the
pivotal moments in renita's life at Oak
Hills and during her growing up that
informed her present tense Journey
so I'm going to read from three parts of
the novel tonight an excerpt with a
little skipping around from the first
chapter and then a chapter from the
middle of the book and then the preface
so kind of moving backwards and I'm
going to talk a little bit between and
around what I read to give a a bit of
framework
so here are
renita's opening words
so this is um February 2019
when she gets out
I live my life forward and backward
seems like my body remembers what I
can't afford to forget
I'll be carrying on trying to choose
right and then the past comes for me
rumbling from my chest into my shoulders
pushing through my neck and up into my
head I try and answer its call own where
all I've been remember even when
forgetting feels like the only Mercy
four years of captivity and here I sit
on this hard plastic chair surrounded by
cinder block about to leave Oak Hills
waiting to be thrown back to the world
and I cannot get still my knees
Jackhammer my feet tap they got Wills of
their own my inner locking fingers
steeple and flatten and steeple I try
and empty my mind but my Oak Hills life
Thunders to the surface and flashes
before me like those shifting pieces of
colored glass in the tan Kaleidoscope I
had when I was six damn really on my out
day which is stressful enough
I chose a pomegranate and try to see
myself holding it broken open in my
hands leathery skin pointy stock jeweled
seeds and I can just about feel the
shape and weight of it again when I hear
the shout did I say you're free to go
and I'm surprised to find myself
standing up
I look the Overseer in the eye why give
him a name when all I am is inmate and
reign in my anger as I sit my ass back
down
it's true what they say about time
slowing down the shorter you get these
last few days of inch by me hoping and
praying I've got it in me to keep doing
right I wait to get back the belongings
I came in with wondering what my stuff
will look like to me now clothes that no
longer fit sheep pleather purse full of
what lip gloss suspended license empty
wallet two keys that no longer open
anything
dear God dear power greater than me
whoever whatever you are let me prove I
deserve to be a mother to Amara and Theo
let me handle my business work my
program stay on track keep away from
Temptation avoid the people who can pull
me down
in here meetings give you the fellowship
that gets you through and a place to say
to remember you're a human with a story
that's got a next chapter even if the
confessing is excruciating I'll find a
meeting and go every day if I have to
own being powerless and Powerful choose
right
Behind the Walls in this concrete desert
everything's regulated and decided for
you all the everyday stuff the what's
and The Whens wake up and go to Chow get
your meds go outside and come back in
take a shower go to sleep line up for
this sit down and wait for that and all
those things that on the outside you do
and pay no attention Behind the Walls
there's a high points of your day
makes me feel like that German Shepherd
of Jaspers he named him King and kept
him in a chain link Corridor nobody ever
played with him or loved on him he lived
to eat buff that floor scrape those
plates sew labels into these t-shirts
one after another and then some more and
so American flags for the folks who hate
your kind or jab you with improve
yourself with classes and groups all day
long you're told what and when and how
and the cost of defiance too
and You Hear The Echoes of ancestors
Whispering that though the best chance
of survival may be submission that could
also be the death of you and love
affection touch the stuff that makes
your heart keep beating Contraband now
who I ask can keep alive that way
nothing much grows in here unless you go
hard against the script to keep alive
you got to choose what you can small
though it may seem imagine yourself past
the razor wire notice those trees and
birds weigh in the distance look at the
sky and picture it whole
you got to see yourself free from the
demon that rides you believing something
new something clean can happen after all
Behind the Walls nothing small and
choosing it's something precious and it
means life just might have some mystery
in store for you
I Choose You Maxine once told me and
you're against the rules
yesterday at the end of my little
leaving party I stood there as she left
the day room before me all of my
well-wishers were there Gwen and her
latest boo Avis crocheting her endless
blanket Eldora and the family she builds
and mothers in here even my new Sally
Keisha came though she still thinks she
can do her time solo we ate the
makeshift treats and canteen snacks they
all chipped in and everyone said what
they'd do if it was them getting out and
when it was over I watched Maxine's
proud upright Back Fade Away
tender tough Maxine along with her free
world free world walk and the way she
breaks down the politics of just about
everything 24 7. her ink and her No
Nonsense way nonsense away and her legal
know-how there's a world of other stuff
inside she can talk up pomegranates and
make me taste them
she can conjure grass or clouds or corn
fields tell Chesapeake river banks and
make me feel the current and the muddy
floor
I wanted to run after her call out to
her touch her I love that back that's
what I was thinking it's moles and scars
it's tats it's it's defiant pride no
matter what she's been through like most
of us in here the only sleep she knows
is broken
last night in my sew with the card
everyone signed and the little in spite
of gifts from the leaving party so sweet
and painful and I I sat in my cell with
the card everyone signed and the little
in spite of gifts from the leaving party
so sweet and painful and started
counting down the last bit of time I
owed
and I'm skipping forward just a little
bit I gathered up my worldly possessions
starting a pile on my bunk laid out my
second string beater sneakers t-shirts
socks two of the unsexiest bras you ever
saw and a week's worth of high-waisted
gray cotton underwear you can't really
call panties comb and hair grease
wounded dictionary I unfolded the loose
leaf paper Eldora pushed into my hand
today and my eyes teared up as I looked
at what she'd shared with me from last
Summer's garden plot
though she had so little to spare pale
discs from her bell peppers and zucchini
seeds smooth and eye shaped I'd already
returned everything I borrowed from the
donated library that made up the one
cubic foot of reading and writing
material allowed and passed on my flip
top tuna and ramen noodles
traded envelopes and paper for extra
socks put aside my extra toilet paper
for Keisha along with the little bars of
soap that made me itchy and ashy toss my
shower flip-flops and that was it what I
had to show for my Oak Hills life
I was already wearing my good sneakers
my thermals and the windbreaker that
passes for a winter coat looking at my
list of Boston area n a meetings before
adding them to the pile I tried not to
be cynical about the names
Freedom Express clean and proud the
solution South End Miracles I read
through the affirmations I put on index
cards remembering how embarrassed I was
at first by their corniness certain that
Jasper was having a good laugh at them
at me from the afterlife the cards and
letters and artwork from Amara and Theo
the program from Daddy's funeral service
and the kites vaccines left for me over
the last two and a half years I keep
that cash inside the Bible a missionary
prison volunteer gave me the little
paper messages that gave me and Maxine
another way of touching and added some
mystery and Discovery to a world of
regulations and taboos
no Sacred Space in here except the ones
we create we may do and left them the
behind the day room microwave where even
if they were found they could not be
tied to us Milagros to be added to the
free things list we make out loud and
the one I keep on my own
Maxine got me plugged into recognizing
and naming the things that cost nothing
and don't depend on permission the
things available to everyone present and
past tense future two one hopes the
smell of new cut grass skipping Stones a
curl of white birch bark
eyelash kisses reading looking walking
even if it's only round and round the
yard
and then this last piece should be a
short piece heart sick at losing Maxine
as I gain my freedom I tried to focus on
the blessing of having been with her at
all
and then I named what I was grateful for
moving from macro to micro I had someone
who'd love me right
people on the outside who never stopped
showing up
children I could still earn back
1159 clean days but who's counting and a
novel I just finished reading that was
echoing through me
trees that would soon be in reach and
the photo of Amara torn down the middle
by a Shakedown boot heel had survived I
had mended it and here it was on the
pile right beside me
Okay so
so
um in this novel I I wanted to examine
experience as generational historical
contemporary that had been wounding and
also to depict forces that have been
sustaining and healing now as the
framework for renita's Journey is the
emotional and psychological toll of this
society's retributive carceral and
criminal legal systems I wanted to make
readers feel the dehumanization and
deprivation that Renita and her fellow
imprisoned women experience
I wanted to show how addiction and
Trauma and sexual violence paved the way
to imprisonment
and I wanted to connect the trauma of
incarceration to this society's history
of enslavement its convict Leasing and
Jim Crow systems it's racial terrorism
share cropping and exploitation through
forced and unpaid and low-wage labor
and also I wanted to show the spirit of
resistance that is healing empowering
and ongoing and that is a fundamental
aspect of the story of black survival in
this country and throughout the diaspora
the forces of collective action kinship
imagination
connectedness nature creative expression
love have always inspired us to make a
way out of no way
for the second excerpt I'm going to read
a chapter one that is necessarily
painful
from about halfway through the novel and
it this this when I was in the third
person narrator's voice and it flashes
back to a visit renita's father makes
with her children to Oak Hills when she
has been locked up for a year
[Applause]
okay so this is 2016 at Oak Hills
they listened for their names visualize
their people coming through the Trap
bargained with their higher Powers today
God willing they would get a visit
if they heard their names they answered
with relief and often tears if they
didn't there was another absence to add
to all the others as they receded
further and further from the Free World
Renita felt blessed her family was
coming she focused on her little bit of
forward motion and even with what would
follow she couldn't wait to be with them
a year in and clean
back at the jail post arrest her her
father had been two feet away and
unreachable on the other side of the
glass that was magnifier and mirror
she'd watch him mouthing words she
couldn't hear until she pointed to the
phone she was holding and the one beside
him before he left like everyone else
she had pressed her hand to the glass
and he'd done the same
how well she knew that poem that was
nearly twice the size of hers and oil
stained when she moved hers away obeying
the order to return to herself and his
lingered on the glass she had choked
back sobs
at Oak Hills the glass partition was
gone but she knew The Passage through
the Trap was still a trial if he made it
there after the hour and a half Drive
he'd be sitting with Amara and Theo
along with all the other expectant
families waiting to be called
marooned on the waiting room pews worn
out Elders tried to keep control of the
kids they had in tow
dressed in matching outfits boys and
navy and girls in pink hair freshly done
and skin lotion they chased each other
round and round until a frown from a
guard or a warning from a grandma
brought them in line want me to tell
your mama how you're acting why couldn't
they just sit quietly the elders shook
their heads and tried to get ready for
the metal detector and the stamp the
Heartbreak and the inexplicable
situation in which they found themselves
the making do and acting happy and all
the questions they were so unequipped to
answer too much to manage and not enough
help or time or money or energy or
thanks kids who would not obey pressing
with their wives and them aunties
grandmas left to deal with it no good
explanation for why mama had been taking
way up here why she was gone again no
good explanation for any of it when
would they get there and why did the bus
ride take so long why did the bathroom
smell that way and have no toilet paper
why were there no toys to play with why
did they search the youngest one's
diaper why didn't the man in blue ever
speak to them even to answer their highs
why was mama living so far away why did
they have to wait so long
how could they explain any of it and how
could they unravel why sometimes even
though you came all the way up there on
the bus because the car needed fixing or
was taking someone else to work and
you've done each and everything
correctly abiding by the rules for
dressing and touching and talking and
being they call the code 99 and lock the
place down and you turn around and went
home without any good explanation of why
they couldn't see Mama that month
because they answered just because
matter of fact they had questions of
their own they'd like to ask why anyone
thought it was a good idea to degrade
and shame parents in front of their
children to separate them and punish
them and why their children's glistening
and newly braided hair was seen only as
a way to smuggle Contraband they'd like
to ask who after all would want to keep
people locked up for a living I'd rather
be on unemployment they thought I'd
rather be on welfare for the rest of my
goddamn life look at that one over there
behind the Plexiglas and the counter now
thinking he's something other than a
Slave
they might have had no choice about
doing as they've been ordered but they
could decide to never ever give the
guards the satisfaction of looking them
in the eye
after Lennox had surrendered his driver
license and produced the kids birth
certificates and proof of guardianship
he put their outer layers of layers of
clothing along with his watch wallet
eyeglasses and phone and a locker and
deposited a quarter in exchange for a
little orange key
wait he said gently pulling Amara back
to remove her barrettes and then opening
the locker to add them and get another
coin Jesse was still talking about the
blow of having to surrender her gold
chain with the praying hands pendant to
a CEO's custody after she'd made it into
the Trap
they found seats beside another family
while a drug detection dog walked past
sniffing at their legs most of those who
sat waiting knew the dog would not stop
at them there was nothing to detect so
still they couldn't help tumbling back
to the lurking ambush of the countryside
and the stop and Frist Terror of the
city and it never ceased to unnerve the
knowledge that they could suddenly
disastrously run afoul of the law which
had never meant to serve or protect them
at last month's visit when five-year-old
Theo has re had reached out to pet the
dog the guard had cut him off with a
cold knife edge no touching he's working
and Theo had cried he hadn't stopped
mentioning the rebuke and today he clung
to lennox's arm as man and dog walked by
all around them restless and nervous
kids goofed argued wove in and out of
the benches but instead of pinging
around with the Restless energy
Amara and theosac motionless and
deflated when Lennox smiled at the three
stair-step kids beside him the toddler
hit her face in her Grandma's sleeve
the middle one smiled and and pointed to
her missing front teeth and the eldest
said hi mister their mama locked up too
Grandma apologized pulling him closer
and launched into what she told them on
the bus about how to act and then they
were called and she was getting to her
feet pulling her string of little ones
along
why can't they call us Amara ass with
sons Sullen sadness
again and again Lennox looked at his
wrist though the only thing to see was a
pale band of Freckle brown skin he
pulled the locker key from his pocket
and put it back three times the slacks
and buttoned down he wore whenever he
was not at work were well within the
rules but he looked at the dress code
posted on the wall in English and
Spanish for men
no blue denim pants no cargo pants no
double layered clothing no sweatsuits no
hooded sweatshirts or jackets no
t-shirts no pockets with holes it was
more challenging for women as Jesse had
found she'd been turned away once for
excessive pockets no skirts with slits
no skirts more than three inches above
the knee no shorts no skorts what in
God's name was a sport he'd asked her no
tank tops no halter tops no scarves no
low-cut tops no form-fitting stretch
pants no bathing suits another question
for his sister who would wear a bathing
suit to the penitentiary
no sheer clothing with or without a bra
at her first visit Jesse's underwire bra
had set off a metal detector and she'd
been taken to a little room for a pat
down search at the hands of a
stone-faced stranger after standing with
her arms outstretched pulling the wire
away from her rib cage and her waistband
from her belly lifting the bottoms of
her feet while trying to balance on one
leg like a ridiculous Flamingo stuck in
the least exotic of places she had come
braless in a pullover that was roomy
enough to hide the evidence of her
drooping middle-aged breasts but not too
baggy to prevent entry
when their turn finally came the heavy
metal door rattled open and shot behind
Lenox and the kids and they were taking
off their shoes and putting them in a
bin turning out their pockets getting
the black light stamps on their wrists
and walking through the metal detector
archway
through it all Lennox stood tall and
looked past the cold dismissive glances
of the guards who puffed out their chest
with self-importance and shook their
heads at the failure of his family his
people
he answered the question on the
clipboard he was handed have you ever
been convicted of a crime riding a big
bold uppercase no
coming through the buzzing gates with a
child by each hand he moved toward
visitation looking down at their feet
and their three gleaming Shadows on the
buff linoleum floor 14 15 16 steps and
23 to go until the next door a right
turn and then 12 more
now sitting for the final weight he
washed the door
as soon as she entered the room Renita
heard the voices of children and saw the
mothers grandmas aunties and sisters who
sat with them and the few men who stood
up stood out like trees on the Prairie
there was Daddy sitting with her babies
who were almost too beautiful to bear
kids chattered and jumped around trying
hard to entertain themselves with out of
date highlights magazines and a few worn
or disabled toys a truck with three
wheels a doll with matted blonde hair
and sightless blue eyes they argued and
complained this one hit me that one
teased me this one took my seat a boy
stood apart arms folded and tucked to
his body silent and wary of his
disappearing reappearing mom
a toddler dressed in the Denim and
Timberlands of a miniature man stiffened
in his mother's insistent hug
a family played Gin Rummy with a deck of
Limp cards
the Oak Hills women ache for these
visits proof that life and love go on
and once they came they weren't sure
they could endure the stilted positivity
the walls with their fake wood paneling
seemed to close in and the cheerful
posters of panda bears and smarmy memes
mocked the lit up soda and junk food
machines enticed only to overcharge and
disappoint and the overseers looked on
with pity and indifference
still there were Miracles the hugs for
bodies craving touch the loving faces
returned to them briefly
smiling in spite of the mournful mood
a mother played peek-a-boo over and over
glowing at how she could make her baby
smile a couple stared with hope and
longing into each other's eyes as they
claimed this now
trying to refuse the blank surveillent
eyes of holstered guards that ravaged
every intimacy Renita made her way to
the children who sat eerily quiet and
the father who was still showing up for
her nodding and saying afternoon to
those she passed as she heard Lynette's
voice inside her head
we speak to each other wherever we are
it binds us it says we're people
whatever they think or say or do she
gave her father a Quick Squeeze and a
kiss and then squatted down to Theo's
height and tried to put her arms around
both kids
Amara's arms hung limp and Theo reached
for her then pulled away
as soon as they sat down the visit
started slipping through her fingers
they just arrived and her first thought
was how long until they had to go
how are you doing Nita Lennox I asked
and she answered fine I'm doing fine
they'd always been good at talking
without going anywhere painful
have you been keeping busy Lennox I
asked hmm I've been reading again it
seems to help in crocheting she asked
about school and after school and the
neighborhood kids but every Triad
conversation lighthearted or probing
fizzled she sent them to the vending
machine she wasn't allowed to use hoping
her father would say something real
about how they were doing but he just
sat between the chairs they had vacated
looking morose she knew his Credo keep
on providing keep on loving how did you
talk about a thing like prison without
making things worse
you feeling good Mama Amara asked
seeming older than her 10 years when the
kids were back at the table and digging
into the snacks resisting the urge to
promise that this time she'd conquer it
this time her recovery would take she
said she was working hard at being well
looking over at the photographer who was
setting up Renita asked cheerfully want
to take a photo the four of us
no one spoke or moved she saw her father
look over at the backdrop of turquoise
water and palm trees and then at the
door
Renita had seen other mothers showing
their photos around and she wanted one
too nodding at the family getting a
picture taken she said look at them
seems like it's a good thing doesn't it
we can both have a copy and that way
we'll be able to see us all together
anytime we want we'll be seeing the same
thing maybe even at the same time
Amaro and Thea looked at each other
Lennox said you all go on the Let It Be
the three of you and when Renita stood
the kids did
the kids did to walking with her to wait
their turn Renita paid for two copies or
her father did since it was his money on
her books and when their turn came they
arranged themselves in front of the 2D
Beach her on one knee with her right arm
around Theo and Amara on her left almost
touching her when she held one of the
copies out to her father he shook his
head and said I'd prefer a different
reference point
she put it on the table in front of him
hoping he changes mine and sat back down
to look at herself with her children
Frozen now in time
the air felt thick and heavy and they
tried for Goodwill but it was a carcass
pit clean they'd gotten Doritos and
candy and soda from the vending machine
taken a photo exhausted their news and
their pretenses and Renita wished she
had things to share but she was on pause
from Life what could she tell them she'd
stood for count at six o'clock 11 15 4
30 and 9 30. she'd gone to ciao watched
a spades game and listen to stories
about plants with tap roots and watch
women sneak affection in the day room
Buffalo floor gone to child twice more
cried herself to sleep with regret and
loneliness she was story poor
they sat silently across from each other
running out the clock
and then leaning across the table to
take their hands Renita went somewhere
she knew wasn't missed it as she opened
her mouth I hate to see you leave when
you're gone I miss you so bad
she saw Amara's face hardening but she
couldn't seem to stop talking I picture
you at the house or at school or playing
out back she saw Amara balling up her
fist but kept going and it's so tough
being away from you sometimes I feel
like my heart's breaking and that was it
Amara blue what about us mama Rita felt
the faint spray of her daughter spit on
her face as she shouted it's like we're
locked up too
her cries shook her skinny 10 year old
body and Minnie Renita looked over at
the CEO standing on the wall and was
flooded with shame
he watched but registered no compassion
no mercy no regard at all as Renita got
up and went to her daughter and took her
in her arms and Theo buried his face in
his Grandpa's side asking granddaddy why
can't mom come home with us when the
tears subsided and Renita went back to
her chair Amara slid the photo closer
and stared at it before saying you'll
get better mama I know you will
Renita felt the last minutes of what
she'd prayed for expire with mourning
and relief and just before the time was
up she couldn't help asking when you
think you'll come again
she watched them disappear from View and
now it was time to pay for her good
fortune and prove the body's innocence
herded into a private room those lucky
enough to have had a visit face three
cos one a female who had been detailed
there for the protection of the women
inside
you know the routine she she said with
icy Detachment making clear in case they
missed it that the whole thing meant
less than nothing to her
they did know the routine they learned
it after every visit in the search for
serious Contraband returning from a
funeral the hospital a trip to court and
whenever some Co felt like it
with no choice but survival they strip
like they had so many times looking
straight ahead and looking back to all
the other takings embedded in their
cells human cargo passages an auction
block appraisals
oh escapes and captures rapes and other
unrecorded conquests lynching to
entertain others and warn their kind
chain gangs and coffin cells fire hoses
and dog whistles and flaming crosses
police on the other side of the gun and
on their necks
they handed their clothes over for
inspection burying the bodies that had
kept track of their mishaps and hurdings
of the accidents and want and illness
and aggression that had left their marks
along with the things they chose to say
in dark blue ballpoint Inc their flesh
said here's where I fell off my bike
where I scraped myself climbing that
fence where my adolescent back knee
bloomed
this is from my c-section with my
firstborn and here's the mark from
fighting off that klansman seal
here's the cigarette burn my ex gave me
to remember him when I tried to get free
here are the traces of the tracks I used
to hide and this is my first boyfriend's
name Inked half my life ago
the fat around my middle is the story of
canteen ships and empty calories of salt
and starch and sugar that have passed
for nourishment inside the walls and
this is where I muscled up lifting and
planking to defeat to defend myself and
fill the time
here's what my body's got to say about
the days and months and years spent
where doctors and dentists and fresh air
and sunlight have been in short supply
they spread their feet apart lifted each
one to show the soul wiggled their toes
leaned forward and shook out their hair
folded each ear forward tilted their
heads back to expose the nostrils opened
their mouths wide lifted their tongues
rolled their top and bottom lips raised
both arms
lifted their breasts and their fat rolls
pulled their any belly buttons open
wrang their fingers through their pubes
and spread their squatted cough
three times turned around bent over
spread their ass cheeks coughed again
three times
they tried to go elsewhere concentrated
on the doorway bit their cheeks but they
could feel the inside wounds the tally
kept from the punishments the things
they had been named and deemed the ways
they had tried and fallen short from the
poisons in their blood and lungs that
had seemed like Liberation from the ones
who broke and entered using kinship and
prayer as passwords from the daily wound
of being reckoned less than human the
toll of being thrown away like trash
silently they chanted this is my body it
is still here and it is still mine and
it is known worse than this along with
its portion of pleasure and kindness and
love
it was mine
it is mine it will be mine but it is
also just a body and I can leave it and
go past her past feeling past anything
you can do to me in here today
okay I know that was a lot
so so
um you know in that in that chapter we
feel that his the pain of historical
generational and interpersonal violence
echoing in the bodies and The Souls of
the characters and and we also feel this
struggle to be human and complex and
defiant and hopeful and loving within
the context of oppressive State
Authority
I'm not going to leave you there though
with the last um short excerpt I'm going
to give you uh some of the hope and the
possibility that our threaded through
renita's journey of healing and
self-acceptance and autonomy so
um informing renita's addiction are are
there ravages of her experience and her
cultural inheritance and yet the
generative resources around and within
her can be discovered and retrieved so
here here I'm going to read the preface
which gives you the framework for the
novel
this is just two pages
mama was gone and not gone she had
disappeared into the hospital while
Renita was at school getting tamed and
stuffed with facts and equations and
there she lay immobilized by tubes and
wires
Renita had Stood Beside her hospital bed
watching the blue ventilator bag feeling
empty
trying to understand how Janita Geneva
Atwater had been felled by something as
Tiny as a blood clot
she had seen her dying and after the
mourners filed past Renita at the weight
grateful for the phrase that helped them
navigate the sudden woe sorry so sorry
so sorry for your loss she had Stood
Beside the coffin and stared at her
mother lying in its White Satin folds
like a parody of a fancy gift box
display
the shiny wig daddy knew she would have
wanted low on her forehead like a helmet
skin waxy and mouth pressed shut
eyes closed to her for good now
she had seen her dead but she heard her
mother's voice in the back door Alcove
at the table in the basement
and now she would never please her never
tell her what she was keeping inside
never love her more than she feared her
a month after the funeral she sat across
from Auntie Jessie picking at one of the
casseroles the church ladies kept
bringing
she'd brought a book to the table which
had never been allowed but there were
fewer shouts and Shout knots now that
Jesse had joined daddy at the house
until things eased up
he stretched out work as long as
possible and escaped to go fishing on
the weekends and both he and Jesse tried
to Stave off the bloated Gloom with food
encyclopedia facts artificial cheer
neither one talked about Geneva neither
one asked Renita about her sadness
and what kept her what hurt kept
haunting
this was the family way sorry and what
hurt kept haunting like a Hungry Ghost
she heard the front door open and close
and there was daddy in the archway
smiling like a Moonlighting Jester
chuckling from his belly like he was
launching a magic trick he pulled the
donut ore from a brown paper bag and
Renita told herself to smile
she'd seen photos and drawings of
pomegranates but not a real one where'd
you get that she asked more edgy than
she intended and his smile wobbled she'd
seen photos and drawings of pomegranates
but not a real one
I'm sorry
it was my place your birthday getting
lost in the shuffle and whatnot I
thought he began she looked away Eclipse
was more like it
he put the fruit in her hands there's no
making up for what's passed but this
here it's got some surprising and
wonderful news buried just inside
expecting a whole lot of nothing her
fingers studied the scratched and
ordinary skin he said they should wait
to open it sometimes waiting made things
better
you hungry Lenox Auntie Jessie asked
getting him a plate and listening as he
told about the engine repairs and paint
Restorations that had filled his day
she kept him chattering while Renita
muted their voices in her head turning
the pomegranate to take in its flat and
Faded spots pressing on the sharp Crown
at the top
and when she was about to get up and
wait on something else he said let's
open it
or Anita peel back the Rind and pried
the bloodshot gems from the spongy
membrane that held the whole thing
together she was struck silent awed by
the wild design of it and by the little
bursts of sour sweet juice from the
seeds that turned her fingers red
there was a whole world strange and
crazy beautiful underneath the skin
layer on crooked layer of Ruby crystals
and Chambers like inside a heart
so
just to wrap up
so so we are all left to Grapple with
the echoing losses of our lives but but
our bodies and our vision and our voices
can be reclaimed in our hearts alongside
the losses our abundance and possibility
and the beauty around and within and
between us the gifts we've been given
the free things all belong to us and we
may find our hands filled perhaps
through memory and Imagination with what
we need and it may be something every
day or seemingly small or ordinary on
the outside and wondrous Within
thank you
[Applause]
I guess
okay all right so I guess Ruth is gonna
lead us in some questions in the
questions that was wonderful I want to
say that I read this maybe a year ago
yeah the galley and I I really hearing
it read I remembered the detail the the
Exquisite detail and and
the the way every sentence
weighs a lot every sentence matters and
now I have to read it again oh it's
really beautiful thank you yeah it's
true yeah I'm supposed to do uh ask you
to
put your questions to this wonderful
woman
um and and she will answer them probably
I will try she will try yeah
um I just learned
or I just remembered really uh with
um the Rosh Hashanah
celebrations that
you're supposed to eat pomegranates at
Jewish New Year that it's a symbol of
the new year which is makes it a you
know another layer of meaning to this
title it's lovely yeah
um
do you want me to talk about that a
little sure okay I'm about to find my
why because people that's that's often a
question I get why pomegranates or and
um and I guess the so uh I began with
pomegranates because a friend of mine
who was incarcerated
set told me that she thought of a
pomegranate as representing the rare and
precious Act of choosing when you're
incarcerated and so that was what I this
story has had different iterations it
was originally part of a longer book
about uh longer novel about 10 people
who are incarcerated and then I you know
I gave up on that and pulled renita's
story she was one of those characters
out of that and and developed you know
her her own novel from that but so
that's what I started with but then
um I think you know as writers we have
we have seeds that we begin with and
then we work and revise and and certain
things gather meaning and become
thematic concerns like in ways that we
didn't necessarily anticipate so I
it came to to suggest this idea of the
heart and the holding in it all the
things that that you are all the things
you've been and done all the things that
have been done you know to and for you
uh and that as Renee moves toward
accepting her full story you know the
the losses the
missteps you know um along with
everything else she comes to see you
know she comes to see her experience
that way and and her heart that way and
that you know you need everything you
have have been and done and uh for your
full story so and then there's all the
all of the
um you know Mythic uh significance it
has cross-culturally you know symbol of
prosperity and fertility and
um so so it has beginnings and
beginnings and Beginnings yeah with the
new year so so those are some of the
things it came to represent over the
course of the book so it became to be
the central sort of symbol I want to I
want to just say a word about
one of the characters in this book
because I've read all of Ellen's work
and she always does she always has one
of these characters it's Maxine in this
book A wise person who knows how to cut
through the
the
dehumanization of
the modern corporate world basically
and to remind
to remind herself and to remind the ones
that she loves about what matters and
where meaning in hears in life
and she and Helen always manages to
create such a character and those are my
favorite characters yeah and Maxine is
the one in this one she's wonderful yeah
I'm I'm going to read Maxine especially
yes she is powerful yeah she's an
instrumental yes in renita's healing you
know
unusual to have a novel that's focused
on incarcerated women yes
what made you decide to bring some
Humanity to this population
did you hear it yeah we're supposed to
say
why do I write about incarceration yeah
why why write about incarcerated women
yeah
um well
my father was planted the seed I think
for this book in me you know in my
growing up he was a criminal defense
lawyer his whole professional life and
and he just he imparted certain
understandings to me I mean some of them
are were that um that everybody's life
is a lot life is complicated and
um worth
seeing and and hearing about and not not
a lot of us grow up without uh full
opportunities and choices and justices a
fiction for some of us and and I think
those sort of politics were what you
know drove him to do to do the work he
did so so he he gave me those
understandings but but also because the
people that he represented were not
invisible you know or other to me they
were part of our community that was the
understanding I got you know and I have
he also gave me a sense both my parents
did that I was that I had a
responsibility you know to use the
access and the privilege that I had to
to speak about about What mattered so I
guess I'd always wanted to you know
write something about incarceration and
so I started volunteering first at a
County House of Correction for a year on
an experimental therapeutic unit and
that tended to be that was men they'd
been in and out in it so it this was
South Bay where you serve up to two and
a half years so they're been a revolving
door addiction at the root of a lot of
the a lot of people's lives and they'd
been in and out and in and out and the
idea was what if what could what could
we create what kind of unit could we
create that would you know interrupt
that that cycle and so I volunteered
along with a lot of other people there
was someone who taught
um
Shakespeare they did Hamlet and there
was there were people who taught
meditation and life skills and and I
taught I did a little storytelling and
I'm not sure you could really call it
writing exactly because the literacy
levels really varied and they were all
not all English speakers but there it
was they were workshops to get people
thinking about
what had mattered in their lives and to
try to begin to tell tell stories about
that and then I got into a I was able it
was hard to find places that would let
me volunteer because you know prisons
don't want writers to come in and then
write an expose so it's a little
challenging it was a little bit
challenging to get in but then I spent
many many years
15 17 years going to Bay State and uh
that's a it was a medium security person
for for men and and then uh after some
years of going and doing it was a little
bit more writing oriented but still
storytelling really and I was one of
many volunteers who went to to do
whatever it is they did in their life to
bring that you know come and teach
philosophy or talk about science or
whatever you know and then uh I was with
Penn New England I helped start a which
a more formal organized creative writing
program and that ran for eight years at
that prison in it
um
Middlesex which was a
pre-release facility related to
Framingham the women's prison so those
are some of the I've taught in some
other contacts too but those were the
the experiences that really I drew on
and that really formed me and when I
started going I wasn't really sure what
shape it would take or what would it be
stories or a novel or why I really
didn't know but I just listened for a
couple of years and then the characters
began to take shape and and that first
novel that was called life without that
was five women in five men so I was
actually interested in in both and then
um
you know that I I wasn't able to get
that book into the world and then I I
you know pulled from it and
um
and decided that Renita had a fuller
story so I had the like the Armature for
the story from the way she had a she was
one of these characters threaded through
that earlier book but you know fleshed
it out it changed a lot over the five
years of writing and and you really do
get a sense from reading the book of
what it's like to be in jail I mean I
thought it was very I mean it was very
interesting yeah
um because daily life came alive yeah
and just you know and disturbing I know
that
sometimes just reading that writing it
was hard and reading it is you know what
the chapter that I just read but I guess
I do I mean to disturb you I mean if
over two million people live like that
and we could we should know about care
about it and imagine it but um it is it
is difficult territory I will say that
right
that's the hardest after I think in
there which is yeah yes
thinking about
writing decision so some of the
devastating sees you right like I
understand what like do you
think
get yourself in there if you associate
entirely yeah
a couple hours of writing yeah
how so the question is how do you
prepare yourself to write how do you get
into the mood how do you is that right
well the heart for the heart for the
hardest part for the hard part how do
you write the difficult parts right
this is hard for me to imagine how I
would how I would do that yeah
um when I first started like working on
that earlier novel life without my sound
was really little and I did find I found
it hard because I wanted to
you know be
uh you know this positive force for him
and so I think that I struggled with it
in those early days a little bit but you
know he's grown now anyway
um I don't know it's I mean writing is I
think if it's what you do then you
commit to it and you have it and part of
what allows you to go the difficult
places and also deal with just the
uncertainty and doubt of writing which
is horrible you know it's pretty
horrible to to Fathom is is by having a
practice you know so I think I have a I
have a and it's not a it has evolved
into something not too complicated I sit
down and I work you know and I do that
before I do anything else you know in
the day and I try to do that every day
if not if if I'm teaching it it becomes
more difficult and I and in terms of
emotional difficulty
um I think you you draw on what you know
about those those pain about pain and
difficulty about you know I haven't been
through this experience but I know some
things about violation you know and uh
and being wounded and uh and the
difficulty of coming to terms with that
of facing that so you know you it's it's
um
it's tough but you you uh
you pull on your own experience I don't
know I put my head down on the table and
cried sometimes when I was ready you
know but that's the that section and and
I I think uh
I don't know there's other things that
Renita goes through you know the
childhood experiences or some of her her
trauma too that she's coming to terms
with and and some of the love
relationships she's had you know and uh
some I realized as I was writing her her
relationship with Jasper you know I used
I used what I what I knew of that too
and those were probably the maybe
because the parallels were so were so
direct because I do know something about
saddling or letting yourself letting
oneself be mistreated or you know the
remaining silent or uh you know not not
standing up for yourself or wanting so
you know to be loved that you give
yourself away so you know I was pulling
on all of those things and that was
those were really painful but I don't
know it was probably therapeutic too it
was hard it was hard I don't think
there's any writing is really hard you
know every time you do it and if if
you're going somewhere difficult to see
but you know like Dorothy Allen says
Allison says if you aren't terrified
then you're not doing anything on the
page so
I don't know it's I think you commit for
me anyway I commit to it I have a
practice and I just understand that
being rocked by is going to be part of
the territory
yes
[Music]
how you differentiate in your writing
the external reality
the external struggles like
incarceration and social injustice and
that thing that are generational and
embodied and felt and kind of persistent
just give her a lived experience yeah
I guess it's all connected I mean I
think we live it in that connected way
and for her it's you know it's all
connected I mean it's something you know
the the mother trauma
um being emotionally invalidated by her
mother sort of there's a kind of Erasure
that goes on you know that that is
and then she's well I don't want to give
up a story away but other other you know
childhood trauma she experiences that
that's con the addiction is about is a
is a sane response right in fact you
know to that to those experiences and so
um the need for Oblivion or to be to be
you know soothed so and then that you
know it's the addiction that leads her
to incarcerate incarceration so it's a
you know it's all connected like in her
story
uh plot wise or you know emotionally and
psychologically but it's connected for
all of us I think you know and that's I
think that's the other idea about the
pomegranate heart you know is that it's
all it's all in there it's all part of
part of you know who you are when she
finally she has to go to psychotherapy
because that's mandated for family
reunification so and then she makes this
journey with she becomes to trust this
it's like black gay psychotherapist and
there's a bond between them and and
um and she
she says to him once she's finally been
able to speak some of the things she's
never told that have happened to her you
know it's never going to go away and
he's like no no it's it's not it's part
of you part of you but you can uh live
out you know differently with respect to
it or it can play a different role you
know in in the way that you live and so
uh you know I guess a talking circularly
a bit but it I think it's it's all
connected all the different things that
happen all in the heart all part of you
and if interrogated and examined and you
know Works through you can those things
can play a different role you know but
they're there part of your story always
there's a lot of seeds in that
pomegranate yeah yeah there are yeah
hey I'm Stephen
okay thank you yeah but you can done you
can dodge the question
this book is so much about
I mean the joy of the inside of the
pomegranate is contained in the
crusty outside which is contained in the
occasion of its appearance and
um
remita's problems is what's going on
inside her body but then her body is
then that's contained within her body
but her body is getting in the family
and a prison and then the prison is
contained in a structure of laws and
then it turns into a story about stories
within stories so you're always
containers and
incarceration becomes a really
complicated metaphor
I guess my question is
you've worked with so many people for
whom incarceration is not a metaphor but
a fast yeah yeah
do you ask their permission
how do you how do you
yeah well when I start when with the
people I volunteered with I I was honest
that I was going to write but I was
writing something and they read some of
the stories some of the stories that
were part of life without were published
and I they read some of those and I yes
I did I was honest about it I didn't
want it you know I I wanted to earn the
stories because I hadn't had those
direct experiences and and did not feel
appropriative or uh
yes I showed them some face yeah
um
so I'm not sure in terms of the
containment though
I'm not sure that's an interesting idea
of like sort of concentric
circles or something and that that's
what our lives are like like a widening
out of and I would say in intersecting I
guess all of it connecting up as well
um
I don't know did I answer your questions
yeah no no that's fine
there are people for whom it's not a
metaphor yeah
well well I hope it doesn't feel like a
metaphor when you read it I I mean I
think that's the that's the power of
fiction is that it opens up the
emotional and live experience of you
know of of the character so you know I I
mean I think there's so much powerful
work social science work and you know I
don't know anthropological work and uh
data about incarceration but what gets
you to experience the realness is is
fiction and so that's why that's what I
thought my contribution could be so I
certainly hope it doesn't feel like a
metaphor is one of the tools a writer
has to make that lived experience at
home you know but I I hope hope it
doesn't feel like that when you're
reading
oh yeah okay well you know poet so yeah
but you know what I mean the metaphor is
in service to
lead reality yeah to this to to the way
that that you receive you know the the
story and the way that you're hopefully
you know expanded by the story
Michelle
[Music]
from the inside
we get from yeah
yeah imagine
yeah
you know have you
have you knew how did I feel out about
that yeah
I have um I have had some people who've
been incarcerated at ratings and come up
to me and say I don't know it resonated
or captured you know they're
experiencing I was just in Atlanta doing
a fundraiser for an organization called
um I was there to talk at Emory but also
ended up doing this thing for mothers be
mothers
motherhood Beyond bars is the
organization and it helps women who
actually give birth
in prison and their kid then their kids
are taking you know from them and try to
keep the connection between these kids
and their mothers going and um they I
was my publisher donated 50 books and
they are giving those book most of those
books too women on the inside so I mean
hopefully there'll be a way to a way to
hear you know some feedback that's neat
yeah
yes
excess things in a way that you may not
if you know it's not fictional but the
framing of the book and
I mean even in Reading uh about your
experience with incarcerated
people does not
gives it a reality that in some way
doesn't make it seem fictional
and so how do you
how do you
you offer your interactions as as a
source of your inspiration but how do
you kind of allow people to feel that
that fictional intimacy you know what I
mean yeah distance themselves
how do you do that um how do you manage
to make it real
[Music]
yeah
um
I mean you're sort of like asking
like the core question is how do you
write a story or how do you you know how
do you I mean you you I think fiction
news is you know the facts of experience
as a jumping off point you know and that
then your job is to imagine you know and
the writer's job is to imagine lives
different than her own you know always I
think and to draw on her own experience
and understanding and and research you
know I did the volunteering I also read
a lot and watched films and uh you know
and there's there's things like The
Marshall Project which is the biggest
Clearinghouse about the criminal legal
system and incarceration as it has a
website and they have a column Life
inside where people who are incarcerated
right you know and you get details and
you get so I guess the goal was how what
are the details that are going to make
it ring true that are going to make it
you know and so some of that's having
enough details about what daily life is
you know is like or
um
there there's that kind of thing there's
that kind of uh
it's like the Flannery O'Connor thing
fiction requires a strictest attention
to the real right to the concrete so you
have those concrete details you've done
enough research and talked to enough
people and you know absorbed enough to
know to to figure out which things
which details are going to communicate a
sense of realness right and then I guess
the rest of it though is the emotional
psychological realness so you build
characters you know and you do that bit
by bit I with through revision and
revision and revision and uh figuring
out how somebody is going to talk and
making I guess giving the characters
complexity and depth you know and
um Renita I fit for her you know she had
to have the certain wounds and and part
of the reasons you know that she had to
be
um had to have experienced some of the
trauma she had is because it because of
the data we have about uh incarceration
so for example a 2016 Vera Institute of
Justice study found that incar that 86
percent of women incarcerated had
experienced sexual violence in their
lives and uh 82 percent has struggled
struggled with addiction with substance
use disorder and uh and also almost 80
percent of uh incarcerated women are
mothers many of them raising you know
children on their own so you know I
wanted to be true to those realities and
so some of the things I I have you know
made happen to her
uh were important in that sense right
and then and then you know just asking
so what are the kind of you know what
makes a person you know make the uh
I don't want to say Choice exactly but
what you know what drives what drives
somebody like like Grenada toward you
know addiction and toward it starts out
with us Vicodin and pills like that and
then in the last experience it's it's
heroin and that's largely because of the
man she gets involved well you know what
is the psychological what's the
background what's the makeup what's the
life history you know that would that
would make her
um you know that would drive her or land
her you know where where she ends up at
Oak Hills and then so there's all of
that part but then to make her complex
and a real person on the page she also
has to have resources to work with
because I want her to have I I believe
she get will get out and make it right I
believe she has what it takes you know
to to get her kids back and own her her
love for Maxine and accept herself and
maybe she'll we all will continue to
screw up right now that's what that's
what life's like but she but that she
will be on continue on her journey of of
autonomy and healing and and
self-acceptance so you know I decided
she she would be a reader you know
because she because books are the kind
books can save us right they are they've
been the saving thing in my life you
know my mother as my dad gave me those
things I mentioned my mom gave me books
to C by and she was a literature
Professor so I you know I am drawing on
my own experience but I also met a lot
of incarcerated people for you know who
who kept alive kept you know that way
through through Reading and through
knowledge and and so then you know I
asked well what's the how does she come
to reading and I come up with for
example that her father gives her
encyclopedias and encourages her to be
interested in the world and
intellectually interested and curious in
the world you know so those are some
things some resources I I give her she
sings she has stopped singing Because of
uh the trauma that has happened to her
and so then you know but music is a
thing and um dancing is it I give her
enough
um you know things to drawn and and pull
on that she has a that she has a chance
and then she's got a family you know
this that stands by her
um
and you know has sometimes drawn a line
though uh and that's I you know
something about what it is to love
someone who struggles with addiction you
know so I I have some things to draw and
loved ones and family members who
struggle with that issue you know so I
try to do justice to that with the
detail so I could go on and on but I
guess I'm trying to illustrate like you
ask you ask yourself as a writer what
what could have what is you have to be
curious I think about what makes people
do what they do you know so what could
it be that has happened to her that what
would make her
you know behave this way and then
we're all complicated you know not none
of us are whole and undivided so she
would I wanted her to have the
complexity of both
the the
um
uh the things that the things that later
Oak Hills but also the things that will
help her to survive and then sometimes
it's the intervention of somebody like
Maxine you know is and Maxine is you
know she's wounded but she's Fierce and
she's also political and she gets she's
able to give Renee a piece a couple of
pieces that she needs for that puzzle to
move forward as well you know I sort of
they have a kind of they share a kind of
black laboratory politics right so she's
able to to develop that in her and she
has a kind of con defy she calls it
constructive Defiance you know a way of
being in the world like that and so
um and an imagination she says there's a
imagination deficit in here what can we
do about that right so so she kind of
awakens or develops that that resource
in her and then the father you know
along with the along with the
encyclopedias you know they grew a
garden when she was little and I guess I
think um maybe I would say that books
and nature uh connectedness to Nature
and it's healing properties are the two
biggest things she has to to draw on so
I don't know that's I'm I'm babbling no
but but you know that I think that's how
how fiction writers work you know
the reader even with your book jacket
more information about your process than
maybe we usually have so the research
that you've done it you make that you
know exclusive in some ways through your
acknowledgments of the people's job
so we know you can draw from that and I
don't think that's always information
that we have yeah we just assume perhaps
yeah it's imaginary as opposed to maybe
having some Roots yeah that's
interesting but but yeah you know but
but I think ultimately like I was saying
about the metaphor you know that's in
service to making it live like there you
could do you could read everything there
is about it about a topic and you could
watch every movie and interview people
but you still have to breathe life into
the characters on the page and the PLA
and you still have to create a sense of
place you know and I don't know some of
that's from teaching fiction writing for
for these 28 years at MIT you know but
your flat character setting those are
the elements of a story and you know you
have you have to make that live and you
do that
um in lots of ways in all those ways I
guess I was describing so
yeah yeah
so I have to say again that was
absolutely beautiful I have not read a
novel straight through like this in a
really really long time but one of the
things I want to ask you about because I
felt it as I was invited into the story
into radina's life they're a moments
when I'm like she's not going to make it
damn how is the story gonna I was
stopping myself from going to the end
and reading it
so I could calm my nerves like she's
listening to me again so how and how
would you handle those moments when you
were telling in it
the whole
to the hope that she then has to find a
way to hold on to oh and get us to the
end and I didn't cheat I swear to God
I I let myself
well that's a great because what you
said is means the most to me because
that means you cared about her I made
her a person and you cared right and
that stuff I've done my job you know but
um I knew she I wanted I knew so it
wasn't a mystery to me but I had to
I knew how I wanted was going to end up
you know but I guess but I think what uh
so suspense is you create suspense with
the withholding of information right so
I think there's I mean I had to have her
make some stumbles right she has a
couple of stumbles and and as always
within herself in this sort of you know
War dilemma or you know struggling to be
your best self like like like we all are
um but I guess the world doesn't make it
easy for her yeah well and I so that was
important to show how hard it was you
know to show all the different all the
different stumbles but but then to one
of my students um
said that uh it was a lot it was very
painful all of the the you know back the
historical stuff that that's that you
know the third person narrator
um delivers but that she always felt
hope and so you know I guess I tried to
have even when she's in in the struggles
you know about whether to use or when
you know encountering the man she had
who had gotten her using heroin and then
how to you know keeping him at Bay or
dealing with all the the pitfalls and
maybe forgiving herself and opening up
to the therapist there are all these
challenges you know that she I wanted so
I guess I tried to show her struggling
with them and the emotional complex
psychological complexity of that and and
then in terms of plotting I think you
know you keep the reader Hook by not by
withholding some
some of the information so you try to
you know that's that's about plotting
and I think you get that right just with
a lot of revision
because I think there was I think there
was an earlier version that was a little
bit too
too linear for you know her her recovery
or her healing was a little too linear
so so I tried to complicate it and
yeah
okay
that's right yeah
book signing yes excellent thank you so
much everybody
[Applause]